[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten
guten abend die verzweiflung wächst am
flughafen von kabul heute versuchten
tausende menschen die rettende flugzeuge
zu erreichen das chaos hält an die
internationalen truppen schaffen es
nicht ordnung in die situation vor dem
flughafengelände zu bringen der
innenbereich des flughafens wird durch
die us-streitkräfte kontrolliert vor
allem die eingangstüre zum militärischen
teil im norden sind kaum erreichbar und
schwer passierbar so etwas wie eine prüf
oder ein abfertigungssystem gibt es
nicht die taliban blockierten die
zugänge teils mit stockschlägen und
warnschüssen zudem sind die
hauptzufahrtsstraßen zum flughafen
verstopft wegen des andrangs der vielen
fluchtwilligen luckwald fast den tag in
kabul zusammen
kein durchkommen schon auf dem weg zum
flughafen menschen aus kabul aber auch
viele familien aus der provinz die vor
den taliban geflohen waren sie alle
hoffen darauf in den rettenden flieger
zu kommen die wenigsten haben pässe oder
wissen etwas von evakuierungs listen
ich sage den leuten sie sollen zu hause
bleiben hierher kommen es zwecklos eine
verrückte situation
am nordtor dem eingang zum militärischen
teil des airport sind es 1000 chaos und
verzweiflung
überforderte afghanische und
amerikanische soldaten versuchen immer
wieder mit gewehr seifen die menge
zurückzudrängen auch frauen und kinder
ein deutscher zivilist wurde auf dem weg
zum flughafen angeschossen er soll
demnächst ausgeflogen werden
bislang konnten schon 18.000 menschen
aus kabel evakuiert werden
1640 an bord von bundeswehrmaschinen
aber hunderte deutsche warten noch auf
eine ausreise zwei transporthubschrauber
sollen ab morgen verstärken
und so für den fall dass wir dort eine
solche situation haben dass einzelne zu
holen
abseits des flughafens scheint sich
wieder ein alltag in kabul einzustellen
auch wenn die taliban überall im
straßenbild sichtbar sind die wenigen
afghanen die sich vor der kamera äußern
bleiben vorsichtig
bislang ist es ruhig sie belästigen ich
hoffe mal das bleibt auch so
das welternährungsprogramm der vereinten
nationen warnt vor einer
versorgungskrise ein drittel der 39
millionen afghanen sei von hunger
bedroht zwei millionen kinder unter
angeht
unterdessen kursieren in den sozialen
medien erster propagandavideos der
taliban aus der afghanischen provinz
nach einem internen un-bericht suchen
die radikalislamisten inzwischen
ungeachtet der angekündigten amnestie
systematisch nach gegnern im land
ehemalige regierungsbeamte sollen
bereits in gefangenschaft sein
der amerikanische präsident joe biden
wandte sich am abend an die
amerikanische öffentlichkeit mit einem
versprechen
um es klar zu sagen wir bringen euch
heim ja immer tee wissen in washington
hat die rede verfolgt voraussetzung
dafür für dieses versprechen wäre
natürlich das chaos am flughafen
irgendwie in den griff zu bekommen
wie soll das geschehen was will der
präsident ändern
ja das wichtigste ist ganz offenbar dass
man diesen stau am flughafen abbau denn
da ist heute sieben stunden lang kein
einziger flieger aus kabul abgeflogen
warum weil in doha dort wo die flieger
hingeflogen sind eben zu viele menschen
bereit sind die aufnahmekapazität ist
erschöpft deswegen haben die amerikaner
beschlossen dass sie die evakuierten
auch in andere militärbasen bringen zum
beispiel nach ramstein in deutschland da
ist vorhin auch der erste flieger
eingetroffen das soll ein bisschen
diesen stau auflösen dadurch sollen
menschen auch schneller die vor den
toren stehen eben auf das gelände des
flughafens kommen können der präsident
hat aus signalisiert seine zusage gilt
nicht nur für amerikaner sondern auch
für alle afghanen die den amerikanern
geholfen haben und hat signalisiert wenn
sie sich melden dann werde man auch
alles wird alles dafür tun sie
herauszubekommen aus afghanistan er
plant aber offenbar nicht eine militär
mission in die stadt zu gehen die
menschen herauszuholen er will auch
nicht den umkreis um den flughafen
vergrößern weil man erstens angst hat
dass der deal mit den taliban platz die
ja momentan noch zugang gewähren und
zweitens weil man angst vor
terroranschlägen hat denn so ein großes
gebiet könnte man nicht sicher schützen
ja die kritik am zu schnellen abzug der
amerikaner ist groß aber fehler räumte
beiden heute nicht ein oder gar eine
strategieänderung
also fehler hat er nicht eingeräumt er
sagte egal wann man den schienen hätte
abzuziehen es wäre immer zu dieser
situation gekommen weil man nicht
schnell genug wirklich alles hätte
organisieren können darüber kann man
sehr streiten wenn man einen besser und
lagen gehabt hätte aber er hat an einer
stelle gesagt und das ist sehr wichtig
welche interessen haben die usa den an
afghanistan nachdem al kaida besiegt ist
und das ist ein klares signal für einen
politikwechsel
afghanistan gilt den usa nichts anderes
als yemen beispielsweise wo man
terrorgefahr dann aus der ferne bekämpft
also ist ein klares signal dass man
afghanistan nicht mehr als den partner
sieht dem man um jeden preis
unterstützen will vielen dank
wir sind für die einschätzung
insgesamt haben die amerikaner so sagt
us-präsident seit juli 13.000 menschen
aus kabul ausgeflogen
über die luftbrücke der bundeswehr waren
ist bis heute abend mehr als
1700 die verteilung der geretteten auf
die bundesländer ist inzwischen
angelaufen in niedersachsen etwa kamen
heute
158 ortskräfte und ihre familien
gehörigen an sie wie auch viele deutsche
mit afghanischen wurzeln die schon
länger hier leben sind jetzt den sorge
um die die es noch nicht aus afghanistan
heraus geschafft haben dominic miller
russ l berichtet
jeden tag fahren sie zum northgate jeden
tag versuchen sie es ohne erfolg diese
videos schickte sala vom flughafen kabul
täglich ihrer besten freundin zu nina
askar in essen wo auch dass allah mit
ihrer familie eigentlich liebt doch sie
kommen nicht durch
doch es bewegt sich nichts trotz
deutscher presse berichtet dass einer
ihrer besten freundin per
sprachnachricht in die ferne
unerreichbare heimat essen enorm und auf
uns schießen kommen nicht rein unsere
pässe haben hier keinen wert wir
schicken also jetzt warten wir auf
unsere eltern weil wir haben uns alle
verloren gehabt
zu haben wir uns auf der tankstelle
versammelt
kommen wir wahrscheinlich chance fand
die ganze
ich sage immer dass sie nicht alleine
ist dass sie nicht die hoffnung aufgeben
soll dass sie stark bleiben soll ich
werde alles dafür tun um sie da raus zu
holen weil das ist einfach kein zustand
in afghanistan da wird geschossen von
köln aus versucht schapur seine eltern
die ebenfalls deutsche staatsbürger sind
irgendwie nach hause zu nutzen die waren
bislang einmal am north gate von dort
hat shops vater seinem sohn dieses video
geschickt
und genau da hin schreibt ihnen das
auswärtige amt heute sollen seine eltern
wieder kommen da hin wo chaos herrscht
und nichts vorangeht es ist wie im krieg
dort in diesem flughafenbereich
das geht einfach nicht dass man ein foto
geschickt und sagt ja hier kommt hier
zum gate
das funktioniert nicht
seine eltern trauen sich nicht mehr zum
flughafen auch er hat ihnen davon
abgeraten
unterdessen sind heute die ersten
militärmaschinen mit afghanischen
kräften in deutschland gelandet unter
anderem hier in hannover kaum jemand hat
gepäck
sehr plötzlich diese menschen dann in
diese maschine gekommen sind nur das
nötigste wenn überhaupt
von daher ist das man kann es kaum
beschreibt ihren örtlichen
bundestagsabgeordneten zu hause in essen
haben sala und ihre familie von kabul
aus kontaktiert vielleicht hat der ja
einen kurzen draht doch bis zum
northgate mutter sara und ihre familie
ausharren reicht der leider nicht ich
habe zum beispiel bei der krisenhotline
des auswärtigen amtes dazu angerufen
habe die nachricht bekommen die seien ja
ohnehin schon privilegiert und man
könnte ihm nicht helfen dann ist das
einfach zu wenig was das auswärtige amt
da macht ich habe den fall jetzt auch
dem verteidigungsministerium zur
kenntnis gegeben die haben zumindest
gesagt dass sie alles versuchen und das
ist auch das was ich da erwartet
sala und ihre familie sind im moment bei
verwandten untergekommen zum flughafen
trauen auch sie sich erstmal nicht mehr
ja die deutsche bundesregierung
bekräftigt möglichst viele ortskräfte
aufnehmen zu wollen in minister seehofer
sprach gestern sogar von allen die nach
deutschland kommen könnten theo koll
aber das scheint ja angesichts der
situation in kabul ein sehr weitgehendes
versprechen zu sein sieht man in berlin
inzwischen eigentlich deutlicher nach
vielen ausschüssen gesprächen und
gegenseitigen vorwürfen warum die
ortskräfte nicht schon im juni juli in
sicherheit gebracht worden und ich
glaube wir haben es offensichtlich mit
einem multiplen organversagen zu tun so
jedenfalls nannte das heute ein
oppositionspolitiker und mir scheint das
trifft es ganz gut die verschiedenen
beteiligten ministerien haben
offensichtlich monatelang über den
richtigen umgang mit afghanischen
kräften gestritten das außenministerium
zeigt aufs innenministerium dort habe
man lange auf einer
sicherheitsüberprüfung vor der einreise
bestanden das wird dort wiederum empört
zurückgewiesen man sei in dieser frage
doch schon früh flexibel gewesen mir
scheint liegt das protokoll des
krisenstabs vom vergangenen freitag vor
und da heißt es vom innenministerium
wenn dieser erst bei ankunft nötig sind
dann machen wir das das haben wir lange
zugesagt aber das steht auch so lange
wie es möglich ist sollten die regulären
verfahren umgesetzt werden und das war
wie gesagt erst vor einer woche und auch
das außenministerium wollte lange die
evakuierung vermeiden wohnen um die
stabilität des afghanischen staates
nicht zu untergraben
hat noch im juni im bundestag gesagt es
gebe ein schwieriges bild wenn afghanen
flugzeug weise das land verließen wie
gesagt multiples organversagen
ja der außenminister heiko maas hat
vorwürfe gegen den bnd erhoben falsch
informiert zu haben jetzt dessen
früherer chef hanning hebt wiederum
vorwürfe zurück ein erster cdu
abgeordneter fordert maß rücktritt
seehofer steht in der kritik was ist die
einschätzung in berlin wetter in sachen
verantwortungsübernahme noch etwas
geschehen so kurz vor der wahl also ich
halte das für äußerst unwahrscheinlich
es sei denn einer der beteiligten
minister würde noch zu einer
wahlentscheidenden belastung für seine
jeweilige parteien gut fünf wochen wird
gewählt und das hat dann mindestens zwei
auswirkungen die gegen rücktritte
sprechen zum einen ganz oberflächlich
ist ja die restlaufzeit der in der
kritik stehenden entscheidungsträger
sehr überschaubar und zweitens würde
jetzt im wahlkampf ein zurücktreten der
minister seine partei quasi mit der
gesamtschuld dieses debakels belasten
momentan wird die schuld ja noch munter
hin und her geschoben damit verliert
dann zwar nicht eine einzelne partei
aber wenn mir das kommentierend erlaubt
sei möglicherweise eine ganze politische
klasse
danke theo koll nach berlin für die
einschätzung so und hier geht es weiter
mit nachrichten können
kunden der deutschen bahn müssen sich
auf einen neuen streik einstellen die
gewerkschaft der lokführer gdl hat ihre
mitglieder zum zweiten mal aufgerufen
die arbeit niederzulegen
im güterverkehr soll der streik schon
morgen nachmittag um 17 uhr beginnen im
personenverkehr sollen die züge ab
montag 2 uhr morgens bis mittwoch 2 uhr
deutschlandweit stillstehen wie schon
bei dem streik in der vergangenen woche
will die bahn den betrieb aufrecht
erhalten
mit etwa einem viertel aller fernzüge
und etwa 40 im regionalverkehr
der tarifkonflikt zwischen gdl und
deutscher bahn kostet millionen pendler
und reisende kraft zeit und nerven und
das obwohl die forderungen der
gewerkschaft und das angebot des
konzerns gar nicht so weit auseinander
liegen stefanie berit wie berechtigt
sind denn die streikmaßnahmen der
gewerkschaft die gdl hat einfach die
volle rückendeckung ihrer mitglieder und
will sich mit einem besseren
tarifabschluss vor allem gegenüber der
größeren konkurrenzgewerkschaft evg
profilieren dabei liegen wie du schon
sagtest die deutsche bahn und die gdl
gar nicht weit auseinander 3,2 prozent
mehr gehalt davon 1,4 in diesem jahr und
600 euro corona prämie fordert die gdl
die bahn dagegen will 3,2 prozent
bezahlen aber erst nach einer nullrunde
20 21 und sie lehnt die korona prämie ab
für uns bahnkunden kommt dieser streik
zur unzeit überfüllte züge und busse
passen gar nicht in eine vierte corona
welle doch genau das spielt der gdl in
die karten der bund als eigentümer der
bahn wird den druck auf den bahnvorstand
erhöhen den tarifkonflikt rasch zu lösen
koste es was es wolle teuer wird dieser
streik so oder so für die bahn und auch
für die kunden denn ab morgen auch noch
vier tage lang der güterverkehr der bahn
ruht dann stört das lieferketten und
einmal mehr werden wichtige vorprodukte
werkstoren nicht rechtzeitig erreichen
bei solchen aussichten mehren sich auch
bei anlegern die bedenken hier in
frankfurt musste man eine ohnehin
schwache börsenwoche verkraften mit
einem leichten plus geht der dax heute
immerhin versöhnlich ins wochenende
vielen dank stefan ina frankfurt
fünf wochen nach der flutkatastrophe im
westen deutschlands sind die betroffenen
regionen noch weit von normalität
entfernt in nordrhein-westfalen erhöhte
sich die zahl der todesopfer auf 48 ein
mann erlag seinen bei der flut
erlittenen verletzungen behörden
anwohner und hilfsorganisationen
beseitigen weiterhin schlamm und unrat
aus zerstörten orten dabei stellt zb das
rote kreuz am 30 ausgabestellen an
derart tausende warme mahlzeiten zur
verfügung finanziert aus spenden
allein durch den spendenaufruf im zdf
für das aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
kamen bislang mehr als 84 millionen euro
zusammen damit die hilfe weiter
unterstützt werden kann bietet das
bündnis weiter um spenden die iban
lautet de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf hochwasser informationen
unter spenden zdf de und im zdf text auf
seite 8 190
sechs tage nach dem verheerenden
erdbeben in haiti ist ein notfallteam
aus deutschland in dem karibikstaat
eingetroffen 33 ärzte pflegekräfte und
sanitäter wollen bei der medizinischen
versorgung helfen im gepäck medikamente
zelte und eine wasseraufbereitungsanlage
die zahl der todesopfer ist auf
2.200 gestiegen mehr als 12.000 menschen
wurden bei dem erdbeben verletzt
hunderttausende haitianer sind auf
humanitäre hilfe angewiesen
in einem land das ohnehin bitter arm ist
im westafrikanischen burkina faso sind
bei einem islamistischen terroranschlag
und anschließenden kämpfen mehr als 120
menschen getötet worden der regierung
zufolge sind unter den opfern 65
zivilisten und fast 60 dschihadisten
den saarländern burkina faso niger und
mali werden die angriffe von extremisten
laut un immer häufiger und brutaler die
zunehmende gewalt treibt immer mehr
menschen in die flucht allein in burkina
faso haben deswegen mehr als 1,2
millionen bewohner ihre dörfer verlassen
sie sind auf der politischen weltbühne
ein so besonderes wie ungleiches paar
angela merkel und wladimir putin
sie kennen sich lange sie sprechen die
sprache des anderen und doch eine
freundschaft ist daraus nicht geworden
zu groß die konflikte zu tief die
differenzen zu gering das vertrauen
gleichwohl putin zeigte respekt vor
angela merkel was die deutsche kanzlerin
für die westlichen verbündeten mitunter
zur mittlerin machte erreicht hat sie
wenig doch die gespräche nie abreißen
lassen die sie immer auch nutzte um
probleme deutlich zu benennen auch heute
bei ihrem letzten besuch als kanzlerin
im kreml für bewerber dort
auch herzliche geste oder der versuch
die kanzlerin aus dem konzept zu bringen
das war nach jedem blumenstrauß eine
heiß diskutierte frage auch heute gibt
es einen und so viel steht fest
sonderlich herzlich wird die begegnung
nicht
heißt dass wir auch viele kritische
fragen miteinander zu besprechen haben
aber ich bin sehr froh dass es trotz
großer differenzen immer gelungen ist
diesen gesprächskanal offen zu halten
angela merkel und wladimir putin treffen
sich schon da ist sie noch einfache
parteivorsitzende die tests beginnen als
die kanzlerin wird conny den labrador
lässt der russische präsident 2007 mal
schlafen mal schnuppern wohl wissend
dass es von merkel heißt sie habe angst
vor hunden ihre ddr vergangenheit hilft
ihr die methoden des kgb mannes zu
durchschauen während des ukraine krieges
stehen die beiden im dauerkontakt in
minsk ringen sie gemeinsam mit
frankreich und der ukraine um frieden
obwohl moskau die separatisten im
sonntaz militärisch unterstützt
akzeptiert merkel dass russland als
vermittler auftritt statt als akteur
auch heute
frau merkel hat viel getan um die
interne krise der ukraine zu lösen
gemeinsam haben wir alle nach einer
möglichkeit gesucht den frieden im
donbass wiederherzustellen
unglücklicherweise ist uns das bisher
nicht gelungen
jahr für jahr wird das verhältnis der
beiden schlechter gründe gibt es viele
die ermordung eines georgios in berlin
der hacker angriff auf den bundestag in
beiden fällen führen die spuren in den
kreml öffentlich zur sprache kommen sie
heute nicht dass angela merkel
ausgerechnet zum jahrestag der
vergiftung von alexei navalny anreist
hat viel empörung in russlands presse
und politik ausgelöst
die verurteilung zum aufenthalt in einer
strafkolonie auf der grundlage eines
früheren urteils dass der europäische
gerichtshof für menschenrechte ja für
und offenkundig unverhältnismäßig
klassifiziert hat nicht akzeptabel und
ich habe gegen mit dem russischen
präsidenten noch einmal die freilassung
von alexei navalny
gefordert angela merkel seit jederzeit
in moskau willkommener die mir putin sie
wissen und fügt hinzu
als das handy der kanzlerin klingelt
natürlich bleiben wir auch telefonisch
in kontakt
die kanzlerin hat den kreml kaum
verlassen da erklärt moskau den letzten
unabhängigen fernsehsender des landes
durch zum ausländischen agenten seinen
repressiven kurs setzt russland unbeirrt
fort damit wird sich bald deutschlands
nächste kanzlerin deutschlands nächster
kanzler auseinandersetzen müssen
die ferienzeit endet und zum alltag der
sich für die deutschen nach und nach
wieder einstellt gehört die erkenntnis
corona ist nicht vorbei es infizieren
sich vor allem die jüngeren die
ungeimpften die vierte welle ist
inzwischen angerollt so schätzt das
robert koch institut ein es meldet
neuinfektionen innerhalb von 24 stunden
2007 hat zwei mehr als vor einer woche
außerdem kamen binnen eines tages 13
todesfälle dazu die sieben tage
incidents liegt jetzt bei
48,8 damit beginnt die welle deutlich
früher als vergangenes jahr als wir erst
im oktober an der schwelle zu 50 standen
allerdings anders als noch letztes jahr
sind inzwischen viele vor allem die
älteren geimpft deshalb können die
inzidenz werte allein nicht mehr die
gleiche aussagekraft haben um die frage
neuer parameter haben sich bund und
länder zuletzt aber herumgedrückt und so
setzen mediziner auf ihre erfahrung und
eigene berechnungen
die politik fährt aufsicht sibylle
bassler
auf der intensivstation der münchen
klinik schwabing kämpfen zurzeit drei
menschen um ihr leben drei von zehn
patienten insgesamt
wir haben im moment eigentlich nur delta
varianten hier bei einem patienten stets
noch auf die bestätigung es deutet aber
alles darauf hin dass er auch eine delta
variante der altersdurchschnitt der
kogit erkranken liegt hier bei etwa 53
jahren 90 prozent sind unter 64 alle
nicht geimpft nüchterne zahlen bittere
fakten die hohe inzidenz sie überrascht
hier niemanden die vierte welle sie sei
zu spüren seit zwei wochen ja
sie greifbar sie ist greifbar nah und
wenn man sich an letztes jahr erinnert
an den august er hat mir ja auch schon
gesagt und man spürt langsam das wider
was kommt und genau das gleiche gefühl
haben wir jetzt auch wieder um das
aktuelle pandemie geschehen künftig
besser bewerten zu können reiche die
sieben tage inzidenz als alleinige
richtwert längst nicht mehr warnen die
ärzte und das schon lange das brauchen
auch noch das thema impfquote auch die
inzidenz aufgeteilt auf altersgruppen
und auch natürlich die zahl der
krankenhäuser anders nur so sei auch
einer überlastung des gesundheitssystems
entgegenzuwirken kritisch im klinischen
bereich könnte es etwa bei einer
inzidenz von 200 werden wenn sie eine
krankenhaus belegung von mehr als zwölf
patienten 100000 einwohner haben und
oder eine intensiv quote von mehr als
zwölf prozent
dann wäre sozusagen eine rote linie
überschritten und einschränkungen im
äußersten fall auch wie der shuttles zu
verhängen doch die appelle die
richtwerte gemeinsam zu justieren
scheinen noch ins leere zu laufen
so wurde auf dem bund länder gipfel zur
corona strategie zwar einiges
geschlossen doch welche werte die
maßnahmen der pandemie bekämpfung
zukünftig bestimmen fehlanzeige der
bundesgesundheitsminister sieht darin
offenbar kein es gab eine große
einigkeit wie wir sicher in herbst und
winter gehen aha regeln auch in bus und
bahn 3 gg im chinesen getestet und vor
allem impfkampagnen die wir noch mal
beschleunigen wollen das ist das ziel
mit diesen drei maßnahmen durch herbst
und winter zu kommen ohne zusätzliche
maßnahmen
doch was soll als richtwert für
eventuelle einschränkungen gelten
shutdowns wegen eines wertes der nicht
mehr wichtig ist noch halten viele
bundesländer an der inzidenz fest zurück
auf die münchner intensivstation hier
fühlen sich manche im team mit dem
pandemie geschehen zunimmt alleine
gelassen seit montag letzter woche kommt
man eigentlich täglich neue patienten
dazu aber was auch für uns das bedeutet
darüber wird nicht mehr gesprochen das
war doch nicht gehandelt also sehr
frustrierend und mit zunehmender corona
fallzahl steckt hier die resignation die
sorge vor der vierten will
die sorge vor der vierten welle wir
bleiben beim thema corona nochmal
nachrichten gundula wegen steigender
infektionszahlen stuft die
bundesregierung kreta und weitere
griechische urlaubsinsel in der
südlichen ägäis ab dienstag als
hochrisiko gebiete ein dagegen werden
die kanarischen inseln und katalonien
von der liste genommen zugleich hat
spanien ab montag deutschland zum
risikogebiet erklärt alle einreisenden
müssen entweder geimpft oder genesen
sein oder eine negativ test vorliegen in
der korona krise besonders engagierte
bürger sind am abend zu gast in schloss
bellevue bundespräsident steinmeier
dankte ihnen den mitarbeitern von
krisenstäben und stadtreinigungen den
erzieherinnen und pflegern
stellvertretend für alle die sich in
dieser schwierigen zeit besonders
engagiert hätten auch würdigte er die
solidarität vor allem der jungen leute
der zweite spieltag in der fußball
bundesliga hat begonnen gerade eben ging
das freitagsspiel zwischen rb leipzig
und dem vfb stuttgart zu ende klar
gewonnen hat leipzig 400
kinder in afrika sind besonders von den
folgen des klimawandels betroffen so das
un-kinderhilfswerk in seinem ersten
klima risiko index fast die hälfte aller
kinder weltweit sei klimabedingten
gefahren ausgesetzt etwa
luftverschmutzung und wasserknappheit
das sei eine schande sagte die
schwedische klimaaktivisten kreta
thunberg die an der unicef präsentation
teilnahm und dann in stockholm mit
fridays for future aktivistinnen für
eine engagierte
klimapolitik demonstrierte genau drei
jahre nach ihrem ersten klima streik und
auch in berlin forderten umweltschützer
mit protestaktionen mehr einsatz für den
klimaschutz
wir produzieren zu viel müll den wir
dann oft auch noch unachtsamen
wegschmeißen so gelangen große mengen
zum beispiel über die flüsse in die
ozeane
besonders plastik bleibt dort auf lange
zeit und findet zusammen weltweit haben
sich bereits fünf riesige müll
kontinente gebildet der plastikmüll im
meer zersetzt sich durch die einwirkung
von uv licht wellenbewegungen und
salzwasser und wird so zu mikro plastik
forscher widmen sich dem thema in vielen
ländern so auch auf der kleinen heide
insel an norwegens westküste
dort wurde vor einigen jahren eher
zufällig entdeckt wie über jahrzehnte
plastik angeschwemmt wurde was ich
daraus lernen lässt zeigt hannah
hebestreit
es ist plastikmüll aus den vergangenen
50 jahren dem sie hier auf lesen
jahrzehntelang hat der nordatlantik
seine dreckige fracht auf dieser
unbewohnten insel abgeladen im laufe der
jahre ist im wahrsten sinne des wortes
gras darüber gewachsen was den
freiwilligen müllsammler die arbeit
schwer macht 30 zentimetern im boden
finden wir immer noch plastikflaschen
das war hier
für alle fälle schockieren
wie ein trichter wirkt die bucht die
sich zur strömung des nordatlantiks
öffnet hier vor der norwegischen küste
in den schären bei bergen wird an dem
eiland das übersetzt kleine heide insel
heißt angeschwemmt was weit entfernt den
weg ins meer gefunden hat
umweltaktivist ohne gar so war vor drei
jahren so schockiert vom zustand der
insel dass er beschloss erforschen zu
lassen was das plastik mit der natur
hier an stellte
die forschung ist sehr wichtig um zu
verstehen welche bedeutung es hat den
zustrom von plastik in die ozeane zu
stoppen wenn es wissenschaftliche
beweise sehen die behörden dass sie
handeln
und so begleitet ihn kurz vor der großen
aufräumaktion ein norwegisches
forscherteam auf die insel
wir werden die auswirkungen auf die
insekten untersuchen und wie die
mikroorganismen im boden aus plastik
reagieren außerdem geht es um mikro
plastiks und wie sich das ausbreitet
wird alle versprechen
die sorge ist groß dass tiere an land
oder im wasser zerfallenes plastik
fressen und es dadurch bestandteil der
nahrungskette wird rund um die insel
sammeln sie muscheln und seeigel um sie
später im labor auf plastik zu
untersuchen
wir wollen herausfinden ob sie das
lastete der körper diese tiere fressen
andere lebewesen also denken wir dass es
eine anhäufung von plastik in der
nahrungskette gibt
in welchem ausmaß das plastik in den öko
haushalt eingreift wird das forscherteam
nach rund zweijähriger auswertungs zeit
ihrer proben wissen es geht vor allem um
das plastik das in mikroskopisch kleine
teile zerfällt und für immer in der
natur bleibt alles andere können sie mit
vereinten kräften weg räumen ist die
nächste flut neues plastik bringt
so viel von uns für heute hier im
anschluss gleich die queens of comedy
und um 23 40 meldet sich anna maria
schuck mit unserem heute-journal update
ist es bis morgen wochenende
[Musik]
gegen abend so geht's sommer das hoch
für die linie bringt uns noch mal einen
schönen sommerlichen samstag aber das
nächste tief steht schon in den
startlöchern
das ist das tief manfred und spätestens
in der nacht auf sonntag bringt es uns
die ersten kräftigen schauer und
gewitter von westen in dieser nacht ist
es noch ruhig im norden sind die
wolkenfelder etwas dichter und es kann
sich mal etwas nebel oder dunst bilden
die temperaturen dazu sinken auf 14 bis
8 grad und steigen morgen über tag doch
aufrecht sommerliche werte von 23 bis 30
grad und nur an den küsten von nord- und
ostsee und auch im nördlichen
brandenburg bleibt es bei 19 bis 22 grad
etwas kühler und nur im norden sind die
wolkenfelder auch mal etwas dichter aber
da wird die sonne wohl auch den
durchbruch schaffen sonst gibt es zum
teil strahlenden sonnenschein besonders
im südwesten und dann kommt das
gewittertief manfred von westen in der
nacht auf sonntag bereits hier an es
wird sich dann im laufe des tages weiter
nach osten ausbreiten machen sie sich
auf unwetter gefasst auf gewitter die
mit hagel platzregen und sturmböen
verbunden sind eng begrenzt können
durchaus 30 bis 60 liter pro
quadratmeter zusammenkommen zum teil
gibt es mehrstündigen dauerregen es wird
danach auch deutlich kühler in der
kommenden woche liegen die temperaturen
dann nur noch bei 17 bis 23 grad aber
von norden setzt sich mehr und mehr die
sonne durch guten abend